voilà là où ça bouge à caen pour parler
musique ce soir avec normandie music
production part il faut rentrer c'est
par là
l'association a déjà trois ans
d'existence d'amendis music production
c'est margot qui devrait nous accueillir
bonjour margot cvo bureau alors vous
allez voir que venez avec nous que ce
qui est incroyable c'est que finalement
on s'attend des locaux de répétition
certains s'attend à un tas de choses
mais en fait c'est juste un ordinateur
et un tout petit bureau fiche de
présentation de l'association pour vous
compreniez l'émission nous avons alors
quel est le but exact de votre
association parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de suture qui est déjà les
groupes dans les musiques actuelles avec
le phare et vous comment vous situez par
rapport à tous ces gens là on rentre pas
dans les cases
les groupes nous ont attaqués en général
parce qu'ils ont besoin de structures
qui les accompagnent et nous contactons
les organismes pour trouver des dates de
concert pour les groupes
margot vous fait les premiers pas
vraiment les tout premiers pas les
artistes même avant qu'ils puissent être
repérées éventuellement par les musiques
actuelles oui en gros on les aide
vraiment à démarrer leur projet donc on
va vraiment des groupes amateurs à ceux
en voie de professionnalisation c'est
cette barrière là qui est la plus
difficile à franchir
on les informe énormément en fait on
répond à leurs questions en général ils
gagnent ils disent pas comment on fait
pour trouver des prestataires pour
trouver des fonds des salles est en fait
nous on s'occupe de répondre à leurs
questions déjà c'est gratuit oui c'est
en fait et on part d'une cotisation de
15 euros par an et à partir de là ils
ont accès à tous les services
voilà pour normandie musique que
production nous on va aller au
portobello à caen ce qu'une nouvelle
salle de spectacle ovo rejoindre sabine
agnel il ya des apéros concert le
mercredi donc demain est-ce que vous
travaillez vous avec le porte vélo oui
ils ont accueilli un groupe normandie
music production et on va organiser une
soirée chez ce courant avril aussi pour
présenter l'association pour présenter
l'association à la presse là où ça bouge
à caen devant le portovelo là qui
dorénavant maintenant tous les
troisièmes mercredis du mois proposera
un apéro concert pour la famille
est-ce que vous avez revu votre
répertoire ou pas du tout pas du tout
donc vous faites comme d'habitude
comme d'habitude ça s'adresse aux
enfants aux adultes à tout le monde
nous avons le traître est fabuleux
fameux r i will survive de gloria gaynor
voilà en somme une heure et puis il y a
pour demain pour demain il y a la
traviata de verdi bien voilà tout à fait
en duo avec mon accordéon
voilà entre autres je ne vais pas tout
dévoiler 18 20 heures 18 de concert nous
comment ça va se passer
eh bien écoutez au premier concert à 18
heures quai plus pour les jeux pour les
plus jeunes paul famille voilà et puis
sur un format un peu plus court
tout est familiale tout le monde peut
venir pour tous et à 19 heures il y aura
un autre concert avec mazars ski qui
proposera son jazz manouche
une fois par mois au portobello une
soirée apéro concert ça commence dès
demain des doigts
dès que je vais devenir adulte
l'humoriste natalie boileau donne tout
sauf la recette du rire garanti à belém
samedi et dimanche
nathalie vient de recevoir un prix à
belfort ce cas la salle des fêtes de
belene
drôle d'oiseau ce soir au molay-littry
jeudi à aunay-sur-odon et mardi à
douvres la délivrande spectacle très
original
cinq comédiens auteurs ont travaillé
pendant une décennie avec l'association
rire médecin au sein des hôpitaux
français résultat ce spectacle à voir
demain à la renaissance de mondeville
bonne soirée